foreign
I'm Steve Brunton and I'm really excited to
introduce you to one of my favorite topics
in all of math, which is Differential Equations.
So this is a short course I'm putting together
this is actually part of a larger sequence
in my engineering math course that I've been
offering for about the last 10 years.
This isone of my favorite courses to teach:
math to engineers, and part one -- kind of the entry
level for this, as I see it -- is really this topic
of differential equations.  So I fell in love
with differential equations, it opened up a whole
world of possibilities, of things you could model,
of things you can understand, of things you can
build with math with equations.  And so
I feel like this is the next logical step afterCalculus.
So if you like Calculus and if you like
the way that you can model the world with how
things change in time, this is
the next step in that progression: differential equations.
We're going to use Calculus to model how
systems change in time.  So this is
one of my favorite examples of a chaotic
dynamical system or differential equation called
the Lorenz system, which was introduced about
a half a century ago, a little bit longer than
that, to model chaotic convection in the atmosphere.
So we'll talk about this a lot later.
This course is meant to be about a seven week series in
a university class, so that's about 20 hours oflectures
that I'm going to be putting togetherhere.
And all that I assume that youknow
know is that you have taken a Calculusclass...
I don't even assume that you remember mostof your Calculus class
I'm assumingthat you are smart and motivated that you have
seen some of these calculus Concepts before
butmaybe you don't remember them and I'm going to build everything up from scratch into this prettyrich and complex world of differential equations.
okay good um so in this video I'm going to kind of
lay out what are the topics we're going to cover
in the class what are some of the applications
that we can open up and enable with this kind
of of analysis of differential equations I'm
inherently going to be folding in linear algebra
because the way I see it really these two topics
should be taught completely together you can't
understand differential equations without linear
algebra and differential equations are probably
the best motivating example to understand linear
algebra better so for me linear algebra is a is a
piece it's a part of differential equations you
can't separate those so we'll talk about topics
applications I'll tell you kind of where this
fits in so I've already told you this is kind of
the next logical piece after calculus but I'll
tell you also what's next Once you learn these
differential equations what new fields of math are
going to be open up to you and I'll tell you how
to get some of the resources that we're going
to use throughout this class so in the video
video description below I'm going to put links to
all of the code for the entire class everything's
going to be available in Python and Matlab there
will be PDF notes for all of the lectures so
every single video is going to have a lecture
notes with it there will be a course website
I'm planning on writing you know a short book on
this topic so maybe by the time you watch this
for those of you time travelers from the future
you know maybe there are actually be you know a
typed up book that you can you can reference but
all of that will be in the the video description
good um and I'll tell you why I think this
is important and interesting it's one of my
favorite topics okay so overview of objects
that are going to be covered in this uh this
course and this kind of 20 hours of material
that fits into this larger engineering math
framework I'm going to start with a simple review
of calculus this will be super brief super short
but you know again I'm going to assume you've
taken calculus but maybe you don't remember it
or maybe it wasn't taught you know in a way that
was motivated by applications so I'm going to you
know start really really simple remind you what
the derivative power you know the derivative is
power rule chain rule but I'm going to also really
kind of early on focus on the Taylor series so you
have some intuition for what this this means
and how this works because we're going to use
Taylor series quite a lot and how we understand
you know Solutions of differential equations
we're actually going to derive exponential
functions and Sines and cosines as Solutions
of differential equations using Taylor series so
this isn't going to be very long but it's very
important so if you need to brush up on calculus
definitely you know don't skip these lectures
and then I'm going to jump right into a system
simple simple ordinary differential equations
so really simple uh differential equations of a
single variable X so X is some quantity that's
changing in time that I care about maybe it's
the population of bunnies and those population
of bunnies is growing and growing and growing
so the rate of change of X my population the
number of bunnies in my population is going
to equal it's going to be a function of my
current population so if I have a hundred bunnies
they're going to grow faster than if I only have
10 bunnies if I have a thousand buddies they'll
grow even faster still so the rate of change of
my population in time is a function it's a
linear proportional to the number of bunnies
I have in my population currently and so this
is going to be like the simplest simplest entry
ode ordinary differential equation and from this
we're going to look at what the solutions are
how to analyze them how to interpret them and
then we're going to generalize that into much
more complicated Rich differential equations so
here dot just means derivative and time that's
shorthand for D DT of X where X is the state of my
system or some variable that I'm keeping track of
as it evolves in time like a bunny population or
like you know the radioactive decay of plutonium
or uranium or something like that so we'll start
off real simple and build everything from scratch
and then we're going to get to more complicated
examples of systems of ordinary differential
equations so now instead of keeping track
of one variable like the population of
bunnies now maybe I'm going to keep track
of lots of variables I care about maybe I
am keeping track of the population of bunnies
and wolves and you know a few other species so
I have a you know multi-dimensional State X
that has a few components you know X1 X2 X3
and so now this differential equation is going
to be a matrix system of differential equations
where a is not a number it's a matrix that
tells me how my my system changes in time as
a linear function of that system okay so systems
of Odes Builds on these simple ones but very very
important lots of examples lots of cool things
you can do with systems of ordinary differential
equations you can model pendula masses on
Springs lots of cool systems you can model
and I'm this is where the linear algebra starts
to come in so when we have systems of ordinary
differential equations you know a is a matrix so
we're going to be talking about linear algebra
and that's essentially the study of you know
matrices and operators and their properties
and specifically I'm going to derive the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of this a matrix
specifically as a useful set of coordinates or
a useful set of of quantities that are used to
solve the system of Odes so we're going to show
what it means to make the system easy to solve
and we're going to find that the way that we
make that system easy to solve is through an
eigenvector coordinate transformation so we're
going to derive eigenvalues and eigenvectors
and motivate them as how we solve systems of
Odes so if you took a linear algebra class in
the past and you were confused by eigenvalues and
eigenvectors or you thought they were unmotivated
that couldn't be farther from the truth they're
very easy to understand they're extremely well
motivated they are the way that we solve systems
of Odes so I'll derive all of that from scratch
and then we're going to go to more complicated
differential equations so instead of linear
differential equations where everything where
the rate of change of X is kind of linearly
proportional to the state X we're going to talk
about non-linear differential equations nonlinear
systems most of the real world is actually
non-linear so when I talk about the populations
of bunnies and wolves you know bunnies or prey
and wolves or Predators They Don't Really behave
linearly there are non-linear interactions that
are important to model and so we'll talk about
those non-linear systems that chaotic example
that movie I showed in my first slide that's an
example of a the solution of a non-linear ordinary
differential equation and a lot of my favorite
systems really are in this uh this realm here so
the motion of the planets and the solar system is
a rich chaotic non-linear system your metabolism
in your body is a non-linear dynamical system
you know presumably your brain is a very high
dimensional complex non-linear system so we'll
talk about those as well and throughout all of
this I'm going to be pinning this to numerics and
computations so we're not only going to be talking
about how do you do all of this with pencil and
paper or on a whiteboard we're also going to
you know fire up Jupiter notebooks in python or
Matlab and we're going to work through how do you
actually simulate these differential equations how
can we plot our Solutions and confirm that they
um you know match our intuition from eigenvalues
and eigenvectors okay so everything I'm going to
do is going to be pinned to computations and I'm
going to do everything in Python everything in
Matlab all of the codes are going to be online
freely available and open okay so you can kind of
pick or choose your language of choice good uh so
that that's the high level overview this is again
approximately seven weeks about 20 hours a little
bit less than 20 hours of content I'm planning and
this fits into the larger framework of um you know
engineering mathematics this is the math you need
to know if you want to do you know real science
and engineering um kind of at the next level
Beyond calculus okay um and again I I always
like to point out you know a lot of what I'm
going to be telling you about is pretty classical
pretty analytic it can almost feel a little dry or
desiccated you know some of it's hundreds of years
old a few hundreds of years old you know most of
the differential equations that we deal with at
least to begin with come from things like Newton's
f equals m a and they're built on the calculus you
know that was around since Newton and leibniz and
so some of this you know can feel pretty classical
and that's okay that's fine we're gonna you know
we need to build somewhere but we're going to use
these techniques these pencil and paper techniques
and I really find it important I want you I want
to convey to you how we use the intuition
we get from paper and pencil calculations
for advanced topics like now in the modern era
with computers we're not limited to paper and
pencil we can simulate very very complex systems
very high dimensional very non-linear things you
could never solve by hand with paper and pencil
things that you know even Isaac Newton couldn't
solve analytically the flow you know the fluid
flow past a cylinder we have to simulate this or
run experiments but the intuition we build for the
classic systems that you can solve with paper with
eigenvalues and eigenvectors and linear systems
and things like that these ordinary differential
equations I'm going to introduce you to we build
a tremendous amount of intuition for how the world
works and how differential equations and dynamical
systems how things change in time from those
analytic classic Solutions and we're going to
carry that intuition with us when we do advanced
modern computational methods or even more recently
data-driven analysis and machine learning methods
so it's very important I'm not just telling you
about things that were discovered 300 years ago
but I want you to know how we can take our you
know analytics Solutions things we can actually
solve in closed form and how we can translate
that to you know really hard Modern Problems
things like you know Advanced simulations and
advanced machine learning models where you know
no one can write down the solution to these we
need computers for these but we can still gain
intuition from the classics so that's a really
important perspective here of how that fits in
good okay um so again this is the overview of
topics I've already walked you through these
um and then the next thing I want to tell
you in this video is how this fits in
to you know once you you learn this material
you invest this 20 hours what does that open
up to you what are the next things and I have
most of these uh next steps actually filmed up
so once you learn this you can go kind of
learn the next things okay so what's next
um you know at least when I teach this as a
two-quarter sequence for my students I have
two weeks on complex analysis so Solutions of
differential equations are naturally going to
involve um you know complex numbers and complex
functions so we'll spend you know not in this
sequence but in a future sequence we'll spend
two weeks of complex analysis uh we'll introduce
Vector calculus and partial differential equations
so generalizing these ordinary differential
equations which are just you know a single
derivative uh in terms of the independent variable
now we're going to look at multiple derivatives
uh of different independent variables so I can
take you know derivatives of a function in time
and in space and relate those that's what's
known as partial differential equation a partial
differential equation and that's inherently built
on the language of vector calculus so this for
me is actually a unit Vector calculus and partial
differential equations go together in the same way
that ordinary differential equations and linear
algebra go together so I'm actually teaching
this as a unit again that's after this kind
of intro to differential equations you can then
learn complex analysis Vector calculus and pdes
uh we're also in this two-quarter sequence going
to introduce the Fourier and Laplace transform
very closely related to differential equations
especially partial differential equations and
I'm not just going to talk about kind of
again classic analytic you know hundreds
of years old Fourier and Laplace transforms I'm
also going to talk about how you do this in a
computer with Discrete Fourier transforms and
things like that how do you use those for you
know not just solving differential equations
how do you use those for things like audio
processing or image compression so this is
kind of one of my favorite topics is really
this is transitioning from you know differential
equations and solving physics problems to maybe
solving data science problems how do I compress
images and audio how do I do things like that
and that segue is very naturally into kind of
and this is only a teaser in my two-quarter uh
engineering math sequence but I have a you know
whole kind of boot camps and courses on this alone
once we have learned about Fourier transforms
and Laplace transforms and we had that kind of
understanding of what linear algebra means it's
really natural to introduce modern data-driven
techniques um you know data decompositions and
machine learning things like the singular value
decomposition which generalize the Fourier
transform to more complex and Rich systems
so this is usually one of my students one of my
my favorite topics and one of the favorite topics
of my students when I teach it this is kind of
all culminating towards these Advanced topics
and I'll also point out the differential equations
you're going to learn in this sequence in this in
this course are going to be very very applicable
to control systems so if you want to learn about
control systems and you want to kind of dive into
the control boot camp this is the starting point
is really learning about differential equations
and linear algebra so that you feel comfortable
so these are all of the topics that are kind of
opened up after you take this course so I'm super
excited like for me this opened up the whole world
of engineering applied math and physics and I hope
uh you know my dream this would be the absolute
best outcome is if even a small fraction of you
feel the same way that this opens up possibilities
for you as well okay good so I hope you can tell
that like I love this I'm passionate about it this
is what I I want to do is to teach you this math
okay so that's what's next um and I think for
the rest of this video I'm just going to give
you some cool examples and applications of
things uh you know cool applications that
you can start studying and understanding once
you have a handle on differential equations
you know one of my passions and and Fields
of Applied interest is fluid mechanics I find
fluids really interesting because like literally
we live and work inside of a fluid and so do all
of our machines your heart is pumping fluid
through your veins um you know every almost
every trillion dollar industry has a working
fluid at the heart of it if you think about
energy Transportation defense Health you know
all of these have fluids wind turbines and you
know Automobiles and trains and planes and cars
all operate in fluids and at the end of the day
fluid dynamics are governed by a set of
differential equations that you can write down
essentially it generalizes Newton's second law of
momentum conservation to fluids okay so this is
an example of a differential equation that we can
understand and solve after these techniques some
other cool examples of differential equations that
come up all the time involve mixing so mixing is a
really big problem industrially and scientifically
how do you let's say you're trying to make not
acid let's say you're trying to make aspirin not
acid maybe maybe you want to make acid but you're
making aspirin you know and a big chemical vat
and so you're adding all these ingredients and you
want to mix them as efficiently as possible you
know how do you put in stirring rods and things
like that to mix this system as efficiently
as possible again this is a dynamical system
uh that that is governed by a set of differential
equations you know that tell you how the system is
going to mix so that chaotic low rents a tractor I
showed you in my first slide that's an example of
a chaotic system that mixes uh efficiently in time
uh and and once you you understand how to solve
differential equations you can do things like
Drop little test particles in these fluid systems
in these Vector Fields so this is a jellyfish and
this is one of my cool one of my favorite examples
where researchers actually measure the vector
field kind of the fluid flow Field behind this
jellyfish using uh you know measurement techniques
experimental measurement techniques and then
thinking about that fluid Vector field or velocity
field as a differential equation you can think of
where little food particles would add vect in
that in that differential equation you could
integrate those forward along this differential
equation and figure out where they'll go
and so for example uh Sean shad and John DeBerry
and Jerry Marsden in this really really cool paper
showed that by integrating these particles you can
find Regions where some particles get ejected into
the propulsive wake of the jellyfish whereas
other particles these green particles get kind
of entrained into the Bell or the feeding region
and so again this is they were using differential
equations and the same exact techniques I'm
going to teach you about in this series to
integrate these test particles and to make this
kind of scientific discovery of how jellyfish eat
I can't help myself I'm also going to show
this really cool kind of follow-on work
uh by by John DeBerry and kit Parker where
they actually design a mechanical jellyfish
this is using I believe tissue from a
mouse or a rat heart some rodent heart
that they put in a fluid that has electrolytes and
they're going to pulse this electrolyte solution
and kind of get this artificial jellyfish to uh
to swim so this is when they start pulsing the the
fluid you know they they put current through that
fluid and this thing starts to pulse and again you
can understand this is a dynamical system it has
a state that varies in time according to rules f
equals m a kinds of rules and so you can write
down a differential equation and understand how
to design and optimize and predict the motion of
this this system uh other things you can do with
differential equations is understand you know
geophysical flows ocean flows climate systems
um you know things like if there's a an oil spill
in the Gulf of Mexico where is that oil going to
go can you predict uh you know where things are
going to go and have your models match again based
on these differential equations and solution
techniques to those differential equations
um this is a cool simulation uh that I
like by Philip dutois where he applied
that same basic analysis to the entire Global
ocean model to figure out where our regions
where mixing occurs and where mixing doesn't
occur and things like that again using basic
techniques and differential equations
that I'll tell you about in this class
for me fluids is really interesting but the
whole world is not just fluids there are
you know climate processes and chemical
processes you know combustion processes
those are all systems that change in
time according to rules and that's all
that a differential equation is is a set of
rules for how your system changes in time
uh good so in this we will also touch on chaos
I've already eluded you know chaos for me is one
of the most fascinating topics in all of Applied
math because it comes up so often when we analyze
systems maybe they seem to be orderly um for some
parameters and when you change a parameter it
becomes very chaotic and unpredictable so that's
you know something we'll talk about is how can
you simulate these systems how can you diagnose
chaos how do you handle it numerically what are
some of the tools to analyze it um you know it
turns out that the solar system the planets in
the solar system have chaotic motion which I
think is kind of interesting so they appear
to be going around in ellipses around the sun
which is true but if you are a a satellite or
if you want to send a space probe to Jupiter
there are these kind of chaotic trajectories
that you can leverage for energy efficient space
travel which is one of my favorite examples of
a dynamical system again a lot of our knowledge
of dynamical systems you know if you go back to
Newton and and leibniz and kind of the classics
a lot of this was motivated by understanding you
know planets in the solar system and a lot of
research still uh goes into to this this topic
um I'll talk about things like you know double
pendula this is one of my favorite tabletop
examples of a chaotic dynamical system so this is
actually me in a lecture in person about 10 years
ago and this is my uh double pendulum setup
that I built I'm just going to run this again
good maybe I'll even bring that into this
lightboard studio I'm trying to figure out
where I would mount it you know I'm going to give
you a lecture on chaos and the double pendulum uh
what it means and how to simulate it things like
that if you have these differential equations
and you understand how to use them you can do
things like do control design and actually you
know harness the Dynamics and overcome that chaos
to do things like stabilize you know a trajectory
that you want and it's super interesting humans
walking so I am an inverted double pendulum
approximately as a walker if you you know shot
novocaine or lidocaine into my legs I'd fall
over because I'm unstable I'm approximately
stable right now sometimes I'm more unstable
than others and you know so even like humans
walking and bio Locomotion very much a dynamical
system governed by differential equations
and we can understand how to control those
systems and how to analyze those systems again
you know using the techniques from this class
um and once you can control these systems you
can do things like Rehabilitation medicine you
can also do things like you know Landing a rocket
this is an inverted pendulum control system that
you're trying to you know you're trying to
land this inverted pendulum with as little
control as possible so again this is a pretty
good example of a differential equation that we
want to write down and analyze and eventually
control the combustion in the rocket engine
also a dynamical system you know the wind flowing
over this thing the fluid flow environment also a
differential equation so it really is kind of
a rich uh almost everything you can think of
as a differential equation at the end of the day
and except things that are static and don't move
okay you hope your bridge that you build is not
a dynamical system but everything else really is
okay good I'm trying to think if there's anything
else that's really the very high level I've been
looking forward to this class for a long time
um you know I've been teaching this for 10 years
this is one of the things I'm most passionate
about and I'm super super excited to you know
to give this to a broader audience um you know
please let me know what's confusing what made
sense what you liked what you didn't like you know
this is going to be a living set of lectures again
all of the resources are going to be made open
you know PDFs of the notes and all of the codes
um I'm excited to walk you through all of this um
you know I'm going to try to release all of these
videos pretty soon so you're going to see this and
then hopefully within a very short amount of time
all of this is going to be following so I'll also
have playlists again in the description so you can
go to that playlist so you don't get lost about
where you know what's the next video you can kind
of follow this in in the right order uh good okay
um just some sneak peeks of things I'm going to
show you because I have a little bit of time left
um you know I'm gonna again I've already mentioned
this but this is one of my absolute favorite
lectures to give because it made so much sense
to me it was something I struggled with and I had
bad explanation after bad explanation and you know
it finally clicked when I started thinking about
eigenvalues and eigenvectors as a coordinate
transformation so eigenvectors the eigenvectors
of of a matrix is a coordinate transformation
it's a matrix that changes my coordinates so that
my differential equation x dot equals ax becomes
diagonal which means it's easy to solve so you
know this is just a teaser I'm going to have a
whole lecture on this but I'm really excited to
share the intuition you know about how eigenvalues
and eigenvectors I think are best understood when
you think about solving differential equations and
when you want to solve differential equations
eigenvalues and eigenvectors are like your most
powerful tools that's how we think about and
analyze and understand all of the Dynamics of
these differential equations so this is going
to be a killer lecture another one you know I'm
going to show you how you take a fluid flow like
this you know how you write down the differential
equation let's say I have a little particle
here I drop a little dust particle X and it
moves around in this fluid flow field U so U is
literally a velocity field a vector field that
varies in Space X and in time t and we're going
to look at how that velocity field that Vector
field of the fluid is a differential equation
for how a passive particle would move if I drop
a little dust particle or a smoke particle
and in this class we're going to look at how
to numerically integrate those test particles
forward throughout that flow field and extract
really interesting useful quantities like
these cool movies and other things like it
for now you know stay tuned this is going to
be a lot we're going to build up real simple
you know from basic calculus that you either
have seen or hopefully remember and then we're
going to hit the ground running it's going
to go slow but it's going to build up quick
and it's going to open up a huge huge set
of engineering applied math possibilities
so I'm super excited stay tuned and
I'll see you next time thanks foreign